it doesn't take a financial expert to
read these graphs and understand the
turmoil the British economy is facing
but after a week of Market convulsions
that push the pound to an all-time low
against the dollar now some relief in
the response of the government
screeching u-turn on their tax cut for
top earners as markets opened across
Europe the pound bounced back in value
against the dollar you've got the pound
Rising roughly back to where it was
before the mini budget
um the pricing on what we think the
banking will do next has changed so
previously we're expecting to add
another two percent or so to interest
rates now expected amount about 1.25 so
the markets are calmer I think and it
sort of gives the government time to go
back to check its homework if you like
and then come back to the markets in a
few weeks with a different forecast in
terms of what they're going to have to
to spend and easy to borrow energy to
cut in terms of government spending but
even after the move the mortgage Market
remains in trouble many house buyers
have seen the cost of loans double since
the government's mini budget would lend
suspending hundreds of offers the
government's Financial credibility
remains in question
this may be a U-turn in the government's
plan to scrap the top rate of tax for
the highest of earners but this is
anything but an ideological U-turn and
the government's dash for economic
growth a budget that could well still
lead to cut some public services
including welfare affecting the poorest
people in the United Kingdom
why because as the government ramps up
borrowing to pay for other tax cuts it
also wants to make so-called efficiency
savings the Prime Minister refusing to
commit to increasing welfare benefits in
line with inflation while at the same
time lifting the cap on Bankers bonuses
in a bid to make Britain more attractive
to investors but it's a gamble many
business owners and even Bankers don't
buy Julia Davies is a member of
patriotic millionaires UK a group of
wealthy investors calling on the
government to increase their tax share
all comes down to an ideology which has
been proven not to work those countries
that do well which deliver the most
welfare they do that on the back of
decent taxation I believe in
responsibility community and society and
that requires those that can afford it
to pay tax so I don't see tax as a
burden I think it's something that we
should all be proud and welcome doing
and just be glad that we can afford to
do it after years of economic stagnation
the government wants to hotwire the
economy into action to embolden trade
and prioritize growth and economic
project government critics say works for
the few instead of the many Neve Barker
Al Jazeera London